[Music]
what is happening there cat hello cat
how you doing there copper what's going
on there reject nation greg here thank
you so much for clicking on this video
with the batman now out in cinemas i
wanted to talk today about every
upcoming batman project confirmed or
rumored between
2022-2025 that's right gregor the title
of a recent cause with wonder video
replaced the word marvel with batman and
came up with a whole video based around
that and you know what if you are a part
of the camp that subscribes to the idea
there's way too much batman out there
well guess what we're getting even way
more like some of these are rumored and
a good amount of these are confirmed so
if you can leave a like and let's just
swing on into action people so first on
the list is the batman dose there will
be no spoilers for the batman here today
but before this movie even came out matt
reeves did say that they have been in
early development on the sequel the
producer recently talking at a red
carpet event i think it was actually the
premiere he did say that even though
this one was pretty much a five year
long process that the batman part two
would take nowhere near as long to get
off the ground so we should probably
expect the batman two within about three
years unless that producer's just being
a dick and he's gonna release it like on
four years and 11 months which would be
annoying however we don't know any
details about this one yet the studios
want us to stay solely focused on the
batman part one we've heard talks about
maybe they could get joker in here which
sounds predictable and generic as much
as i want to see joker in this universe
matt reeves explored the idea of trying
to bring like a realistic mr freeze to
life which i just think would be so much
cooler and obviously this is an early
stage in the career of penguin we know
he's getting a spin-off so maybe penguin
could be the villain in it question goes
to you guys who would you want to be the
villain of the batman part two moving on
we might as well stay on topic and stay
in the matt reeves of bataversy thingy
that's going on we have either two or
three shows confirmed maybe another one
here the reason i say that number is
because there was something that came
out recently that matt reeves said where
he did say we're doing another series
that connects to arkham asylum i didn't
know what that might mean because the
way how this is phrased okay well we
have two confirmed shows right now
another rumored show would this arkham
asylum thing be connected to one of the
shows or would it be its own separate
entity regardless to explore more of
arkham asylum inside of the world matt
reeves has helped create would be
awesome this would be something that
feels probably more unsettling grim you
know realistic what you've seen in the
batman trailers vms in the batman movie
you only get like a taste of it in the
batman film but you do get an idea of
like i would hate to walk through the
halls of this place which i think would
be a fantastic show maybe you can
actually get dr hugo strange involved
but if not doing just like an arkham
asylum based show i think the one where
arkham will make the most sense would
probably be for one that was the first
confirmed series gotham pd i think
that's just a working title right now so
it's where the batman takes place in
year two of him being batman the plot
synopsis that we have so far for this is
the series is set during batman's first
year of operations and focus on
corruption in gotham city according to
various reports in a showcase of dc
fandom the series will focus on a
corrupt gcpd officer in the battle for
his soul now there have been reports
that jeffrey wright will reprise his
role as james gordon for this series you
know if like you've seen the gotham show
like myself that was on fox you might go
well this might be exactly the same
thing when you watch the movie it's
obviously very different and whereas the
movie does take inspiration from the
comic book year one it's not like a
direct adaptation of it i think for this
show it could be way more of an
adaptation of batman year one as much as
i wanted to do its own thing and not be
reliant on a batman appearance i think
this show would totally work with a
batman appearance i kind of sound like
seth rory this would make the most sense
especially because it's taking place
during batman year one and in that comic
book which both batman begins and the
batman draw inspiration from it's gordon
who's really the main character of that
comic book and i always thought it would
be cool if they did some type of
perspective shift where maybe sometimes
you see bruce wayne and sometimes you
see batman but the show never goes out
of its way to go they're one in the same
just keep it locked into like the cops
or gordon's perspective and with the
movie dealing so much with corruption in
the gcpd i think this would be also a
great opportunity to set up more of the
crime families that are established as
well things like the falcone family the
moroni family
other families that aren't coming to
mind right now so next on the list three
four i don't remember catwoman matt
reeves did say that there have been
discussions about zoe kravitz having her
own hbo max show as well or having her
own spin-off series in some capacity and
this would be cool and also for that i
want to talk about the penguin series
which is actually confirmed matt reeves
even recently said we're doing this
penguin series and one of the great
things about that is it's colin farrell
he's like you've never seen him he's so
incredible and he's a scene stealer and
he really is along the way we thought
maybe we could do his character as a
series so i talked to hbo max and showed
them colin in the movie and spoke to
them about what this could be and they
said let's do it we'll do all your all
the batman you want matt reeves will do
it yeah i'm excited for the series dude
and i know this is a completely
different thing even james gunn taking
peacemaker turning that into an hbo max
there was a character that i was like i
don't really want to see a show about
peacemaker i ended up loving the hell
out of it and this would be something
entirely different but led by colin
farrell and it's penguin i'm really
awesome and the reason i'm sort of
combining catwoman and penguin because i
think the same can be said about both
maybe more for penguin i would say than
catwoman this show could do either a
prequel that lead into the events of the
batman or it could be a sequel things
that happen after the batman that's what
a prequel and a sequel are in case you
didn't know or maybe they can like
better call solid where you know usually
i see the past and then you also see the
future either way it sounds like penguin
will be a story that will be fed in
between the batman and the batman too
and i'm really hoping they bring the
events from penguin into the batman too
all right i think i think that's it from
madrid's batman world it's getting to
the point where he's gonna say hey i
like that background actor give him a
show so next upcoming this year is the
flash which is really just a bat verse
movie no i don't know i i actually um
the more i hear about this film sorry to
sound like it really will still be a
flash movie ultimately where batman's
are supporting batman but yeah we know
about this ben affleck set to appear in
here his final appearance he's made
pretty clear he wants it to be his final
performance i'll add and michael keaton
as well who's set to return
we already know let's move on bad girl
now not to be an hbo max show but an hbo
max movie which will take place in the
more established still pretty confusing
dc eu timeline whatever it's going to be
we gotta wait for the flash apparently
to understand what this movie's gonna
really be because gordon will be there
who was introduced in justice league
it's gonna be michael keaton continuing
on as batman and he seems to be really
jazzed about it i don't know if it's him
or his publicist who's putting out
photos of the bat suit on social media
probably his publicist don't really see
michael keaton sitting around being like
this is the right photo on the right
filter for that you know i don't see him
doing that there's rumors of robin
appearing in here as well and and
batgirl of course batgirl barbara gore
finally getting her own thing but
speaking of justice league and confusing
timelines i do believe in the powers of
the multiverse this is being really
demanded and after we got zack snyder's
justice league a film that many many
many thought would never see the light
of day and this is a much bigger
prospect to handle zack snyder's justice
league two and three i really want to
touch on like the ben affleck side of
things do i believe that there's a
possibility he could come back if they
ended up getting us off the ground sure
uh but let's just focus on the fact that
zack snyder's justice league two and
three could continue many of you have
probably already heard by now there's
that warner media discovery merger
happening and we're discovery ceo david
zaslov he's gonna be taking over the
organization there are insiders that
reveal that people like warner brothers
chairman ann sarnoff dc films president
walter hamada warner brothers pictures
group toby emmerich are not expected to
remain three people who are easily zack
snyder's closest friends and apparently
there's another insider that leaked this
of course the leaks were taken with a
grain of salt that zaslov is focused on
producing more content that audiences
seek especially warner media's most
popular ips and reportedly in the year
of 2021 when so many movies had the
option to be streamed and a lot of
movies that should have just been the
theaters went to streaming zack snyder's
justice league i believe was in the top
three of most stream movies of 2021 so
this can present a good opportunity hell
yeah multiverse it off let's get zack
snyder's justice league two and three
i love the batman i'm very curious about
the flash also still really won zack
snyder's justice league two and three
another one that has not been wiped off
the table here one that i really wanted
nightwing person i believe wrote in his
attach to direct this movie is chris
mckay from the lego batman movie and he
said in mid-2021 so this is fairly
recent when we talked about it is that
it's a movie that i still really want to
do i love the character of dick grayson
as a young adult becoming his own kind
of superhero character that was going to
be a father and son story and also a
revenge movie sounds very much like the
lego batman movie which i was really
excited about because there's a lot
going on on that script it was going to
be really primal and paired down on like
a real red meat movie in the best way
i'm batman
i love that world that probably has such
a fun movie but there was a period in my
life when i was really young when i read
a lot of comics and that actually came
from getting introduced into nightwing
so nightwing is the character i've
wanted to see most brought to the big
screen i don't watch titan so i think
he's in there if i'm not mistaken but to
see him in live action form there's so
many actors who could play dick grayson
and at that stage in his life it's a
really interesting character so maybe
with batgirl we could get the
introduction to robin and whoever's cast
is robin could be spinned off into
nightwing the first comics i think i
ever actually read was the hunt for
oracle and that's like the beginnings of
when dick grayson moonlights as a cop
and he moonlights as a vigilante
what's he moonlighting ass takes place
in bloodhaven has the villain
blockbuster of course barbara gordon's
oracle although be very confusing
timeline because you know like she has
to be batgirl for a while before she can
be oracle who is like paralyzed and [ __ ]
so
um just do its own nightwing movie make
the chris mckay one all right who didn't
see this one coming the movie that made
a billion dollars won some oscars joker
2. now not much has known about this
movie it's been reported that the first
draft has at least been submitted they
got the first draft say
sometimes i just laugh way too hard on
my own dumb jokes there's rumors about
lady gaga being courted for this we did
our own video where we were sort of
pitching like what we think the plot of
this film could be recommend you guys go
check that out i actually really love
that video joker 2 it's coming don't be
surprised why would you be surprised all
right and then speaking of nightwing
from earlier this one
i really want this one i really do i'm
gonna preface it with this it doesn't
seem likely at the moment but you never
know crazier [ __ ] has happened the lego
batman movie two so the reason why this
might not happen is because while the
lego batman movie is beloved like a lot
of batman fans usually consider that one
of the top five best batman movies it's
beloved made a good amount of money but
the lego movie two did not do that well
lego ninjago movie didn't do that well
and i believe the rights have been
bought or reverted something either way
they used to be with warner brothers who
obviously does the dc [ __ ] and now the
rights of the lego movie franchise are
over at universal and i don't think
universal's really interested in doing
this and no reports are indicating that
they would be interested in doing it
they probably just want to do their own
thing make it lego fast and furious or
some [ __ ] which actually wouldn't be a
bad idea chris mckay had this to say
recently dan harmon from rick and morty
and michael waldron of rick and morty
and also loki and dr strange multiverse
madness had done a first draft of the
script that was really great it was
truly epic both from an action
standpoint and from a story standpoint
the structure was godfather part two he
kisses robin on the cheek and says i
knew who was you dick a story about
batman's relationship to the justice
league and superman that was well as the
formative moments of the justice league
and batman's relationship with superman
then like this just sounded like a truly
heartfelt movie you know i think that's
something that was really interesting
about the first film was that it starts
off just super funny like it is
hilarious and cool but mainly hilarious
and then it just has such depth to it by
the end and i loved how when talking
about this he mainly spoke about wanting
to explore the development of batman as
a character his relationships learning
how to form connections cutting between
times that just sounds awesome and i
feel like a lot of people really love
this to happen alright another animated
movie here that will have batman dc
league of super pets so there's a
trailer that came out for this did not
see it
honestly i actually haven't i could just
watch it on my own i don't need to have
a camera pointer on me for every trailer
i watch anyway the part of it is this
when the justice league is captured by
lex luthor superman's dog krypto forms a
team of shelter pets who were given
super powers how named ace who becomes
super strong and indestructible a pig
named pb who can grow to giant size a
turtle named merton who becomes super
fast and a squirrel named chip who gains
electric powers and batman's gonna be in
here somewhere moving on batman caped
crusader you thought the mad reeve [ __ ]
was done well it kind of is but it's
kind of not because he's one of the
producers of this so matt reeves jj
abrams and bruce tim are revealed to be
producing this series jj abrams who uh
whose films are loved by everyone
equally described it as a thrilling
cinematic and evocative of batman's noir
roots while diving deeper into the
psychology of these iconic characters
and have bruce tim involved in this
sounds amazing and i think jj abrams
there's a lot of his films i actually do
really love i think he's a better
producer generally than he is a director
to have him involved on the creative
side and that department i think is
awesome and of course with matt reeves
this honestly sounds like this could
shape up to be like an amazing ass
animated series like this really does
sound like this could be something super
special and it's going to be released on
hbo max and cartoon network all right
people the last one i got today check
this out
if you thought cars
that franchise was cool
well have you heard of bat wheels bat
wheels is an upcoming american animated
superhero preschool series starring
crime fighting vehicles alongside dc
superheroes will be on cartoon network
and hbo max so in this show the bat
wheels are reported to be sentient super
powered crime fighting vehicles that
fight alongside our heroes batman robin
batgirl and a host of dc superheroes
they're gonna have been created by the
bat computer and the heroes are
essentially gonna be like kids with
little to no life experience it's gonna
be like cars but would like batman and
guess who's voicing batman this one
actually genuinely surprised the [ __ ]
out of me it was batman's gonna be
voiced by ethan hawk moon knight
now bat wheels he's dominating the comic
sphere man anyway was there one here
that i missed i know we didn't talk
about any upcoming dc animated movies
that are like based on like a comic run
or something or the video games but what
i leave off the list which one here are
you most excited for thanks for joining
me on this journey i'll catch y'all soon